[Music]
El Salvador is one of the deadliest
places on earth
the tiny Central American country is in
the grip of a war among rival gangs and
the police successive governments have
attempted to control the gangs using
force cracking down in the streets and
filling the prison's
last year more than 10 people were
murdered every day
gangsters tattoo their allegiance on
their skin membership is for life in El
Salvador they say the only way to leave
the gang is in a body bag those who
attempt to leave face social stigma and
the threat of execution and other gang
members or the police rehabilitation
programs are practically non-existent
but in the capital city San Salvador a
religious group is trying to help the
gangsters swap the gang for God if God
could change someone like me someone
that has done so many wrong things why
not change all these other men
[Music]
when Wilfredo Gomez was growing up El
Salvador was in the midst of a bloody
civil war that left one in sixty
Salvadorians dead and one in four
displaced
[Applause]
in 1987 gomez like hundreds of thousands
of others fled to the United States on
the streets of Los Angeles he found a
home with the gangs once I get into the
hood I decided to join the gang and I
had to find a way to survive to make
money me so Isis sell heroin Gomez
joined 18th Street named after the area
in LA where most of the gang members
lived they fought for territory with a
rival Salvadorian gang ms-13 a lot of my
friends that I grew up with and they're
joined the gang almost at the same time
then were killed during that war it
wasn't long before he had a run-in with
the police and was put behind bars I got
busted for selling narcotics to survive
and using that at the same time in a bid
to reduce gang violence the Clinton
administration in 1996 passed the law
that meant immigrants convicted of
crimes with a prison sentence of more
than a year would be deported I remember
my mom mentioning a you need to be
careful they'll be pouring people now be
smart stay away from trouble
thousands of gang members were sent back
to El Salvador
including many members of ms-13 and 18th
Street who took their brutal battle for
the streets with them the number of
deported soon rivaled the size of El
Salvador sixteen thousand stroke police
after almost 20 years in the u.s. half
of which was in prison gomez saw the
deportation as his ticket to freedom the
one thing I wanted the most was to be
free so I signed three days later I was
on the plane my way back warrior just
three months after he arrived he was
back in prison serving ten years for
stealing a security guards machine gun
I remember going into prison and they've
just had a massacre the smell of blood
was still in there I'm talk about 150
persons in one cell had sleep there
shower there what are the bathroom there
from his crowded prison cell Gomez found
an unlikely salvation the Christian
people they asked to pray for me so I
told the guide ok pray for me and they
need something happened it's like wine
like a little kid the prayers had a
profound effect on Gomez I had spent
nearly 16 years of my life in prison and
all along I knew that I needed help but
I didn't know who to run to
I had no family the guy that was praying
for me as me following the received
Jesus and I told him that after joining
the church Gomez began to convert other
gangsters to evangelical Christianity
[Applause]
no kidding this oportunidad in 2016
he helped persuade the prison director
to establish a separate area where
religious inmates could live and pray in
peace away from other gang members this
was an attractive proposition and
hundreds of prisoners followed Gomez
some were genuine converts others just
wanted better prison conditions
[Applause]
I have never seen so many guys being
impacted by the gospel guys all tatted
from their face singing praises to the
Lord when I first joined the church it
was about a hundred men in there and
little by little that 100 years make
right now it's over in my hand it's
something was happening I mean gang gang
members don't change just like that in
early 2017 Gomez was given parole in San
Salvador he feared that if he left
prison he would fall back into the gang
on the outside there are a few prospects
for anyone linked to the gang to earn
money legitimately am I surprised there
was someone waiting at the door a
Christian and they had heard about me
through a guy and they had control
before me and he had told them that I
was one of the leaders in prison with
that Christian movement so they brought
me here to this church they made food
for me
celebrating my freedom that was big for
me
since leaving prison Gomez has helped
other newly released gang members find
refuge in a tiny Church in San Salvador
the inmates who convert inside prison
struggle to stay away from the gang once
released only seven former gangsters of
church members on the outside the rest
find their way back to the gang those
who do join the church have a tough
existence they have no money no
prospects in no place in society being
annexed gang member here in Ostrava door
and facing society's rejection it's the
biggest obstacle that I faced so far no
dream of Purdue's Familia mophir deal
the totem of perdido aim of didn't even
wait at all pero Mira a duro pero ahora
que movie near Caminos do not have n
decir una manera
[Music]
yes I made wrong choices I mean my
mistakes but you have me yours
maybe my mistakes is that I put ink on
me maybe your mistake was that you
cheated on your husband maybe my mistake
was then once upon a time I took a life
either way there are mistakes maybe
mines are bigger than yours but I'm
still a human these men once devoted to
gangs now claim to be devoted to the
church in many ways the church is
similar to the gang
both have strict rules a hierarchy and
demand obedience solving El Salvador's
gang problem will take more than
converting a handful of gangsters to
Christianity the question facing El
Salvador in the long term isn't whether
an individual gang member can change but
where the society will create the
conditions that mean they can leave the
gang for good
[Music]
you